this video is sponsored by mubi go to
movie.com thomasflight for your extended
free trial
what does a chimpanzee on a rampage in a
sitcom have to do with two siblings who
are trying to capture images of a UFO
and nope there are two sides of the
story that at first feel somewhat
disconnected at the very opening of the
film we see a POV shot of a horrifying
scene we don't get any context for what
is happening but it's pretty clear
something has gone horribly wrong after
this opening we don't see or hear
anything about this moment again until
OJ and emerald run into Ricky I was a
little Jupe and we learned that he was a
child star in a sitcom that had a
chimpanzee as part of the cast yeah my
pops told me about this shoulder the
monkey went crazy we eventually see a
flashback of what went wrong and within
that scene we see a very traumatized
Little Ricky so what happened really
but there's a moment here that gives
away the connection between this subplot
and the main story listen to how Ricky
tells the story of what happened to him
you haven't seen the badboardy sketch on
SNL
I mean it pretty much nailed it better
than I could when he tells the story he
doesn't give his own first-hand account
of his experience he talks about SNL's
rendition of the event he communicates
and processes his own traumatic
experience not through his own
perspective but through a depiction of
the events Gordon Katan goes off and
it's
it's Katan he's just crushing it he is a
force of nature he is killing on that
stage
I think this Clues us into the idea at
the core of nope a relationship to
spectacle and traumatic events and
images as viewers and creators of those
images the word that we said the most on
set or I said the most was spectacle and
so that was the starting point
um for me in a lot of ways of what I
knew I wanted to give the audience
most of us avoid watching Real Horror
while the industry for fictional horror
movies is huge there are documentaries
of atrocities that are incredibly hard
to watch and deeply horrifying on a
level far beyond the latest bloomhouse
scare that we don't really seek out
because they're truly scary not in the
cathartic therapeutic sense but in a
paradigm shattering existentially
terrifying leave you traumatized or just
gross sense
except maybe we do more than we think we
do we have a really complicated
relationship to images of horrifying
things
on one hand we want to look we all know
it's there
[Music]
no but sometimes we choose not to look
we avert our eyes you know I usually
charge a fee for this
foreign
Ricky has commodified his trauma he's
turned his experience on Gordy's home
into a spectacle that he sells for money
and he's trying to do the same thing
with the UFO eating horses but the only
reason Ricky can even do that is because
people are deeply fascinated by the
horror of the events there's a growing
Gordy's home fan base out there now
this Dutch couple paid me 50K to come in
here and spend the night
OJ and emerald want to capture images of
the thing that killed their father on
camera doing this would accomplish three
things first illuminate the real cause
of their father's death as something
more than just a freak accident they
said it was a problem that killed pops
that thing never made sense to me second
it would create the potential for fame
money and recognition in capturing an
image of the spectacular or the horrific
maybe I'm talking rich and famous for
life because there is a hungry audience
for spectacle and third with their Fame
and money they stand to take back some
of the history of their family's
involvement in Hollywood that was erased
did you know that the very first
assembly of photographs and sequential
order to create a motion picture was a
two-second clip of a black man on a
horse yes it was yes it was look it up
now I know you guys know Edward
moorebridge the grandfather of Motion
Pictures who took the pictures that
created that clip but does anybody know
the name of the black jockey that rode
the horse
foreign
[Music]
films themselves are a kind of
commodification of trauma not real
trauma usually although sometimes the
lines certainly blur like with nope
itself where the Gordy's home storyline
was inspired by real events images of
trauma can help make the trauma more
visible to those who might deny that it
exists it also might even help those who
experience the trauma process it but for
those who bear the responsibility of
capturing the images for those whose
trauma it is for those who don't get to
decide whether they look away or not
capturing it doesn't come without a
cause what we document so
it's gonna do some good
huh
I mean besides the money we can save
some eyes
we can even save Earth
all right
jean jacket the UFO shouldn't be looked
at OJ is the one who figures this out
and is able to avoid being sucked up
into the sky because of it
the power of traumatic images can be
avoided by not looking at them but if we
don't look how do we know it's real how
do we prove to the world that it
happened
you never go wrong with a fried fish
sandwich
there's a scene in nope where OJ emerald
and Angel have all just had this
absolutely horrifying experience
one that totally confirms to them the
presence of the UFO and they're grabbing
food and debriefing afterward and OJ I
don't think it eats you if you don't
look it or not OJ wants to actually talk
about what happened and this is how
emerald and Angel respond RTR bro
yeah
yeah like you're in the room
nobody want to talk about that
I don't really know what this scene is
saying in the grand scheme of the film
but I know one thing I recognize the
feeling this scene is conveying there
have been more times than I care to
mention especially recently where I've
been hanging out with a group of people
and we all just recently learned about
something horrific or terrible through
the news and often there's a tension
between wanting to talk about it and
just put it all out there and wanting to
entirely ignore it and just try to
maintain a sense of normalcy and move on
with our lives in these scenarios what
is the right thing to do what's this
about woman you want to say
I'm sorry
what's wrong it's dumb it wasn't though
on the moment I remember when Russia
first attacked Ukraine I wasn't just
hearing news of this happening for those
first 48 Hours especially I was seeing
POV footage of the attacks happening
from the perspective of ukrainians I'm
absolutely not equating the horror of
seeing those videos with the horror
experienced by the people who are
actually there but it struck me that
this perspective afforded by a
smartphone the very personal and
intimate individual nature of it had an
effect on me that felt very visceral
compared to other footage I had seen of
war in the past smartphones have
genuinely changed the way we View From a
Distance traumatizing and horrific
events
while these exact issues might be on
Peel's mind with nope I think he's
exploring this fundamental tension in a
slightly different context
[Applause]
live analysis dealt with spectacle and
this industry and business of spectacle
and uh and that there's a magic to it
and something that I've I've devoted my
life to being a part of and there's also
something Insidious about it
[Music]
in the opening of the film we see a
strange sort of frame around the credits
we later learned that this is the mouth
of the alien itself
after we see the opening credits the
camera flies inside the mouth and in the
heart of the Beast we see the moybridge
footage the first motion picture and
then it cuts to a similar image of a
horse on a commercial film set what is
this untameable predator in nope
it's the film industry it's impossible
to work in this industry for very long
without having scars of moments where
you feel like you were exploited or feel
like you were infantilized or erased the
movie industry has forgotten and erased
the black horse jockey in the first
motion picture but it doesn't end there
peel is engaging with the Western genre
in this film in addition to the setting
he alludes to Sidney Poitier's classic
Western buck in the preacher one of the
few exceptions to Hollywood's
whitewashing of the American West where
some historians estimate a quarter of
all Cowboys were black a historical
presence that is almost entirely missing
from Hollywood westerns where stories
about famous black cowboys were often
turned into films with a white lead in
nope it's this monster Predator that
kills the black cowboy at the beginning
capturing that monster on film helps
illuminate that but to do so you have to
get close to that thing that can chew
you up and spit you out
the dream I never wake up from
what's terrifying about these scars is
it's it's wound it's it's all wound up
in the the Quest for attention and so
that's why you know Fame is very
destructive to people who don't have a
secure system
peel is examining spectacle in this film
he's looking at it and mulling it around
but he's mostly asking questions peel
doesn't need to offer an answer or
solution to this Duality and I don't
think he does within the film besides
honoring the efforts and Triumph of OJ
and emerald to capture an image of the
monster and in doing so to help correct
some of the Erasure that they've
experienced and that's ultimately what
peel is literally doing with this film
as well he's capturing an image of a
monster the monster of our own
horrifying Fascination and exploitation
of spectacle and in doing so he's
helping to correct some of the Erasure
that black people have experienced in
Hollywood in an interview with uprox
peel talks about the dynamic of having a
scene where people are invited to a
spectacle when that's also what he's
doing with this movie that scene you're
talking about I think has some DNA
connection to that idea that you can
simultaneously invite an audience to a
spectacle and indict them and yourself
for putting it on and needing that
spectacle and he draws a connection
between himself and the character of
Ricky the character he plays is a total
character study it's a unique guy that's
based on I think observations about the
type of trauma that this industry can
inflict on people who are launched into
the machine of attention
I'm very close to that character let's
put it that way I think it's easy for
people to be frustrated or confused by
movies like nope that explore a duality
or tension especially when the
expectation for Peel's work that's been
set up by his past work is that he will
have a pretty clear concise biting
social commentary but I think commentary
that doesn't provide an answer and
instead pokes and prods at an issue and
raises questions is still incredibly
valuable and necessary nope is a
spectacular horror film about the danger
of spectacle it's a big budget Hollywood
film that critiques the Hollywood
industry it's not a movie that can draw
a clear resolution to those dualities
instead it's a film that explores the
queasiness that arises and we're not
sure if something is good or bad but we
find ourselves in the midst of it
mubi is an online hand curated streaming
Cinema with films from all around the
world Classics Art House and Festival
Favorites just recently they added the
master by Paul Thomas Anderson which is
one of the most beautiful movies I've
ever seen you can check it out right now
on mubi in the US they add a new film
every day with an explanation of why you
should check it out which makes mubi a
great place to discover new and
interesting things to watch mubi is one
of my favorite places to find and watch
cinema online check them out today and
get your extended 30-day free trial when
you use my link that's mubi.com
thomasflight or click the link in the
description or on the screen movie.com
thomasflight thanks again to movie for
sponsoring this video
[Music]